[Musique]
ici à comble dans le loiret je vais
monfery mais l'escapade nigérienne ce
village est chargé d'histoire puisqu'il
se situe sur la route commerciale
fluviale qui elles et donnant jusqu'à
paris rencontre avec éric et cali son
fidèle compagnon qui m'attendent dans un
bateau à fond plat
d'ailleurs sa flotte un bateau à fond
plat on va les vérifier ça tout de suite
on attend
ouache monde espagnol eric comment
sauver les riches salut kaminis abord ça
va très bien madame première question
déjà c'est une gabarre du coup le bateau
là c'est non c'est pas une gabarre on
appelle ça un fût trop à fut trop où
aller d'accord des gaillards ici on en a
pas ici c'est un terme qui est pas trop
employés sur la loire on parle plutôt de
chalon chalon et la tout aussi il ya
aussi les tous effectivement notamment
des to cabanes et on a une belle
derrière nous là bas tout cas bonne et
ouais c'est pour les amoureux et tout ça
c'est des on la propose l'été pour un
hébergement insolite on peut passer et
en amoureux sur le corps et on est
d'accord que là on est sûr vraiment un
bateau traditionnel c'est un bateau
tradition % bois celui là effectivement
donc alors à ces deux formes qui
dépensait quelque chose
saucier la tradition c'est ça c'est
ouais c'est quoi ta message de bienvenue
sa message d'accueil ça ça vient des
bateaux victimes à ces débits qui ne
sait pas d'où breaking dawn et des
esprits tordus des vikings écoute alors
c'est parti on peint on avait beau
parent est ce que vous venez avec nous
soit des sportives
[Musique]
et ce pouvoir raconter aux gens lors de
la balade alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est la principale route qui permettait
d'alimenter la capitale paris en
marchandises diverses et variées
périssables non périssables et ça ça a
duré pendant plusieurs à plus d'un
siècle et demi 1700 1850 jusqu'à ce que
les voies ferrées viennent perturber le
juste le business est exactement et ça
en quelques décennies et qui vient qui
vient profiter de ces escapades n'y a
pas d'âge pour monter sur un bateau on a
tout l'équipement de sécurité nécessaire
donc on accueille des bébés en poussette
comme des gens en fauteuil roulant
devait accompagner bière
contre ça déjà c'est un peu trop près de
mode
et désigne comme celle de derrière il y
en a combien de points il y en a
quelques unes en fait ils se sont formés
au fil du temps
celle qu'on a par exemple à notre droite
ont une cinquantaine d'années il faut
savoir qu'à l'époque les il était
entretenu il fallait pas laisser pousser
les arbres sur les lignes parce que en
cas de crue c'était vraiment des
obstacles et des pièges pour les bateaux
et les pompes bien bien bien ou bien on
n'est pas bien là franchement
donc kamini j'ai envie de tester une
nouvelle formule pour nos ballades
d'escapa nigérienne et à lui appelé la
formule koh lanta sa rente un problème
donc vas-y tu peut débarquer kamini yes
à la peinture
elle est bien calé donc je t'explique le
principe qui a mis un drain pose là et
en fait je te dis à la semaine prochaine
c'est la formule koh lanta d'accord
salut salut
mais si la bonne formule jeu bien
bacs lundi moi je ne mange pas à kalisz
appeler s'ils trouvent ira chercher à
bouffer vu qu'on n'a pas le budget pour
acheter le générique de l'émission je
vais devoir le faire tout seul
[Musique]
moi je pensais que c'était une blague à
la passe on sait pas qu'il allait
vraiment nous laisser là tu vois
c'est ta faute ça doit lui faire une
connerie
[Musique]